tomando en cuenta que hoy tengo gripa no
puedo imaginar un mejor tema para un
vídeo que hablar de los virus y bueno
los virus son en cierto nivel las cosas
más fascinantes de toda la biología o
eso al menos en forma de ver porque
estos hacen borrosa la frontera entre lo
que es un objeto inanimado y lo que es
vida a lo que me refiero es que la vida
es algo que reconocemos de una manera
muy sencilla cuando la vemos no es así
si ves que algo nace que algo crece esto
mismo constantemente está cambiando a lo
mejor se mueve a lo mejor no pero
metaboliza las cosas a su alrededor y se
reproduce y luego mueren dices
probablemente eso es vida y dentro de
ese concepto podemos incluir a muchas
cosas que vemos por ejemplo a nosotros o
bueno se me ocurren las bacterias
las bacterias o se me ocurre también no
sé las plantas las plantas y estoy
seguro que estoy destrozado el sistema
taxonómico pero tendemos a reconocer lo
que es vida cuando la vemos ahora bien
todos los virus sólo son un montón de
información genética dentro de una
cápsula hecha de proteína y la
información genética puede venir en
varias formas puede ser no sea a rn
r m
de n o puede ser
n mono catenaria que se distingue de
este poniendo 2 s se enfrente o puede
ser adn bi catenaria que se distingue
poniendo una d s adelante en este caso
el adn de catenaria y bueno los virus
pueden venir en cualquiera de estas
formas pero la idea general es que
tienen información genética y tiene una
cadena de ácidos nucleicos ya sea como
arn mono o bi catenaria o como adn mono
o bi catenaria esta información está
contenida dentro de un tipo de
estructura proteica que se conoce como
cápside y se ve más o menos así el
dibujo clásico de una cápside es algo
más o menos así déjame ver si estoy
haciendo justicia con ello se vería más
o menos así algo así en su forma de cosa
algo más o menos así estoy seguro que
has visto un dibujo de ello y no todos
los virus se deben de ver como esto
porque hay miles de tipos de virus pero
bueno ahorita estamos empezando el vídeo
y entendiendo qué son los virus y todas
las distintas maneras en que se pueden
replicar y hablaremos un poco más de
esto en el futuro aunque sospecho que
probablemente cualquier tipo de
replicación existe en el mundo de los
virus pero realmente son estas cápsulas
que se llaman cápsides proteicas están
hechas por un montón de proteínas juntas
muchas proteínas juntas y bueno adentro
de ellas
hay material genético que bueno puede
ser adn o arn entonces déjame dibujar su
material genético y bueno no
forzosamente esta proteína debe ser
transparente pero si lo fueran se vería
algo más o menos así aquí adentro
tendríamos este material genético dentro
de la cápside entonces la pregunta es
esta cosa de aquí en la vida tiene vida
este virus y bueno si te das cuenta este
virus no crece no cambia no metaboliza
cosas esta cosa está sola con sus
propios recursos y bueno va a estar
sentada sin hacer nada parecido a un
libro o una mesa que sólo están ahí esto
parece ser bastante animado pero justo
aquí es donde empieza el debate porque
lo que sucede es lo siguiente y ojo
puede que me digas hey sal cuando lo
defines de esa manera se ven sólo como
un montón de moléculas que están juntas
eso no es vida pero comienza a verse
como vida cuando de pronto se pone en
contacto con cosas que nosotros
normalmente consideramos vida entonces
lo que hacen los virus el ejemplo
clásico es que un virus se va a sujetar
a una célula y para eso qué te parece si
dibujo aquí a un virus un poco más
pequeño lo voy a dibujar como un
hexágono algo más o menos así
están mis vídeos y bueno lo que va a
hacer es sujetarse a una célula y puede
hacer cualquier tipo de célula puede ser
la célula de un animal o de una planta o
de una bacteria no lo sé pero aquí está
mi celular y las células generalmente
son mucho más grandes que los virus
ahora en el caso de las células que
tienen membrana blanda el virus de
alguna manera se las ingenia para poder
entrar a la célula y lo que pasa
esencialmente es que se puede fusionar
no quiero complicar esto pero a veces
los virus tienen pequeñas membranas y en
un segundo hablaremos de donde obtienen
esas pequeñas membranas que rodean a la
cápside así que la voy a poner más o
menos así y luego estas dos membranas se
fusionan y por lo tanto al fusionarse va
a dar oportunidad de que nuestros virus
entren a la célula este es un método y
otro método eventualmente es muy
parecido es el método en el cual el
virus convence con base a algunos
receptores proteicos en él o receptores
proteicos en la célula de que el virus
no es una partícula extra
para la célula así que se va a ver más o
menos así tengo aquí a mi virus lo voy a
dibujar así y va a ser un tipo de
caballo de troya porque la célula no
quiere tener virus por lo que el virus
debe convencer de alguna manera a la
célula de que necesita consumirlo y
bueno a lo mejor las células solamente
piensa que es algo que necesita consumir
y entonces la idea es que la célula lo
rodea más o menos así va a rodear a este
virus lo voy a poner más o menos así y
eventualmente este lado se funcionará
con este lado y podría ser cientos de
vídeos de cómo los virus trabajan es un
campo de investigación muy estudiado en
este caso el virus quedará adentro de la
célula y a esto se le conoce con el
nombre de endocitosis y ojo la
endocitosis no solamente sucede con los
virus es un mecanismo por el cual pueden
entrar muchas cosas a la célula una vez
dentro el virus se encuentra en el
citoplasma y bueno también hay casos
donde la célula en cuestión
en el caso de las bacterias tenemos una
célula con una cubierta muy dura así que
voy a dibujar por aquí a mi bacteria y
va a ser a una bacteria que tiene una
cubierta muy dura y entonces lo que va a
pasar con el virus es que ni siquiera
entra a la célula voy a dibujar para que
mi virus ojo esto no está escalar
solamente lo estoy dibujando de esta
manera el virus se coloca fuera de la
célula e inyecta su material genético
así que por aquí va a ingresar y
claramente hay una gran variedad de
formas por los cuales los virus entran a
las células pero esto no viene al caso
lo más interesante es que pasan cuando
entran a las células y cuando entran a
la célula y ve a su material genético
dentro de la célula entonces su material
genético notará por aquí y si su
material genético ya está en la forma de
rn va a pasar lo siguiente y no puede
imaginar de hecho todas las maneras
posibles de trabajar de los virus en la
naturaleza pero no las hemos encontrado
las que ya hemos encontrado
son muy variadas entonces si tienes el
rn del virus y digamos que este de aquí
es el núcleo de mi célula lo voy a poner
más o menos así y bueno adentro de él
tenemos su adn así que lo voy a poner
más o menos así es formar cromatina algo
más o menos así aquí tenemos todo
nuestro adn éste normalmente se
transcribe en rn normalmente la célula
si la célula está funcionando de una
manera normal hace que el rn salga del
núcleo y vaya hacia los ribosomas así
que por aquí voy a dibujar a los
ribosomas y bueno por aquí voy a dibujar
a mí a rn va a salir y después junto con
él
me producen estas proteínas recuerda que
el fn codifica para varias proteínas
estoy poniendo más o menos así y bueno
todo esto lo he visto en varios vídeos
estas proteínas se forman y
eventualmente pueden formar distintas
estructuras en la célula
pero lo que hace un virus es apropiarse
de este proceso secuestra a este
mecanismo así que este a rn a rm
esencialmente ira y hará lo mismo que
hacía el adn de la célula pero va a
comenzar a codificar para sus propias
proteínas y obviamente no va a codificar
para las mismas cosas de hecho una de
las primeras proteínas para las que
codifican es una proteína que comienza a
matar el adn y el adn de la célula que
de otra manera competirán contra el
entonces codifica para sus propias
proteínas y estas proteínas comenzarán a
hacer más y más cápside es así que va a
haber más cánceres por aquí más cápside
por acá otra cápside por acá
más y más cápsides y al mismo tiempo
este aire n se está replicando es decir
va a utilizar los mismos mecanismos de
la célula para replicar su adn para
replicar y replicar su a él y ojo el
virus por sí solo sin ayuda de la célula
no haría nada pero una vez que entra la
célula puede usar toda la maquinaria que
tiene la célula para replicarse a sí
mismo y esto me parece sorprendente tan
solo pensar en la bioquímica de cómo
estas moléculas de rn logran entrar de
nuevo a estas capacidades a estas
capacidades no voy a poner se va a
entrar a esta otra también y cuando ya
hay suficientes y todos los recursos de
las células se agotaron los virus
estos nuevos virus que ya se replican a
sí mismo usando todos los mecanismos de
la célula encontrarán la manera de salir
de la célula y bueno la forma en la que
sucede esto y no me gustaría decir la
forma más común porque ni siquiera
todos los tipos distintos de virus que
existen pero una de las formas las que
hablamos es que una vez que suficiente
virus liberan proteínas o más bien dicho
proteínas que se construyeron porque
ellos no las hacen y esencialmente
causan que la célula se mate a sí misma
y que su membrana se disuelvan así que
toda esta membrana se va a disolver
esencialmente la célula se lista la voy
a poner más o menos así las células se
lisa es decir sucede lo que se conoce
como lisis celular y cis celular y lisis
sólo significa que la membrana celular
desaparece y luego todos estos amigos
virus que tenemos aquí pueden salir de
la célula
ahora anteriormente mencioné que algunos
de estos amigos tienen su propia
membrana entonces como estas membranas
lipídicas llegan ahí bueno lo que hacen
otro tipo de virus es que una vez que se
replicaron dentro de la célula ellos
salen sin matar a la célula no tienen
utilizarla y es que recuerda que
esto de lo que he hablado son formas
específicas con las cuales puede
trabajar un virus pero como tenemos
distintos tipos de virus estos hacen
muchas combinaciones que ni siquiera te
puedes imaginar replicando y codificando
sus proteínas y entonces después de
replicarse se va a ver más o menos así
ya tenemos aquí de nuevo nuestro virus y
éste lo que va a hacer es brotar de la
célula y cuando brotan de la célula
esencialmente lo que hacen ambos lo
puedes ver así es empujar esta membrana
celular la van a empujar desde adentro
de la membrana algo más o menos así y
cuando la empujan toman un poco de
membrana toman un poco de membrana aquí
tengo a mi virus y después cuando hayan
enfocado lo suficiente este virus va a
salir
una pequeña parte de la membrana algo
más o menos así y ahora podrás imaginar
porque esto es algo útil porque ahora
tienes esta membrana que de cierta
manera te hace ver cómo esta célula o
como una parte de la célula y entonces
cuando quieres ir a infectar a otra
célula como esta no te verás
necesariamente como una partícula
extraña entonces es una forma muy útil
de verse como algo que no eres y si no
crees que esto es lo suficientemente
raro es decir secuestrar el adn de un
organismo bueno espérate a lo que te voy
a contar los virus pueden cambiar el adn
de un organismo y uno de los ejemplos
más comunes es lo que hace el virus del
de
h que es un retrovirus así que déjame
ponerlo de otro
y esto es increíble porque lo que hace
es que él tiene
rn cuando entra a las células dejan el
dibujarlo aquí tengo aquí a mi virus y
aquí tenemos a rn y voy a suponer que ya
entró a la célula así que mi celular ya
está aquí déjame dibujarla más o menos
así pero este virus tiene adentro de él
una proteína y si te preguntas de dónde
obtuvo esta proteína que estoy poniendo
justo aquí la respuesta es de otra
célula usa aminoácidos de otras células
y sus ribosomas y además sus ácidos
nucleicos y todo para construirse
entonces todas las proteínas que tienen
vienen de otra célula pero vienen con
esta proteína la transcriptasa reversa y
la transcriptasa reversa toma su adn y
lo pasa a 'a' de n lo va a pasar
adn es decir aquí teníamos a rn y este
lo vamos a pasar a the end y esto es
algo muy muy fuerte cuando fue
descubierto esto por primera vez la
gente pensaba que siempre se iba de adn
rn pero al descubrir esto se rompió el
paradigma al codificar el adn a adn
como si no fuera lo suficientemente malo
este incorpora su adn al adn de todas
las células y que si éste es el adn de
la célula hospedera y por aquí voy a
dibujar su núcleo ahora también forma
parte del adn del virus es decir lo que
hace es interferir con el diseño del
material genético de lo que está
infectando y cuando hice el vídeo acerca
de las bacterias dije hey
por cada bacteria humana tenemos 20
células bacterianas y éstas viven con
nosotros y son útiles y son parte de
nosotros y además dije que eran el 10
por ciento de nuestra masa total pero
las bacterias no interfieren ellas no
cambian lo que somos y estos retrovirus
están cambiando nuestro diseño genético
ya lo que me refiero es que mis genes
son muy personales definen quién soy
pero estos amigos entrarán a mi celular
y cambiarán mi diseño genético y una vez
que son parte de mi adn me sucederá el
proceso natural de pasar de adn a rn y
luego a proteínas pero ahora este
proceso también codificar a las
proteínas del virus o algunas veces el
virus entrará en un estado latente y no
hará nada otras veces
si por ejemplo se presenta algún tipo de
desencadenador ambiental activará
nuevamente la codificación de sus
propias proteínas y entonces comenzarán
a codificar para que se formen nuevos
los virus déjenme poner aquí a otros
virus por aquí a otro de ellos y por
aquí a otro más porque se van a producir
muchos más directamente del organismo
del adn de la célula es decir se vuelve
parte del organismo y es que no me puedo
imaginar un modo más íntimo para
volverse parte de un organismo que ser
parte de su adn no me puedo imaginar
ningún otro modo de definir un organismo
que por su adn y bueno esta idea de que
cuando el virus se vuelve parte del adn
de un organismo se llama pro virus así
que este declive es un pro
i
y si esto no te parece lo
suficientemente espeluznante escucha
esto sí esto infecta a una célula de mi
nariz o de mi brazo cuando esta célula
entre en mitosis todas sus hijas serán
genéticamente idénticas por lo que
tendrán el adn viral y a lo mejor puedas
pensar que eso estará bien y bueno lo
importante es que mis hijos no lo
obtendrán es decir que esto no se va a
convertir en parte de mi especie pero no
tiene que infectar solo a las células
somáticas puede infectar también a las
células germinales puede infectar
también a las células que me lees y
recuerda las células germinales son las
que producen gametos
2 en el caso de los hombres
espermatozoides y en el caso de las
mujeres óvulos así que no solamente se
conforman puede infectar a las células
somáticas también infecta células
germinales y como puedes imaginarte una
vez que infectó a una célula germinal es
decir una vez que se volvió parte del
adn de una célula germinal entonces
pasaré ese adn viral a mi hijo o hija y
ellos se lo pasarán a sus hijos y esa
idea por sí sola al menos a mí me parece
ligeramente escalofriante se estima que
las personas tienen cerca del cinco al
ocho por ciento y esto te vas a pensar
acerca de lo que realmente somos los
seres humanos se estima que del 5%
al 8% del genoma humano
hermano en algunos lugares encontré que
es un 8% en otro 5% todo esto es una
estimación viene de los virus
viene de
los vivimos
y esto es impresionante porque cuando
hable de bacterias hable acerca de cosas
que no interferían pero esto con base lo
que se ve en el adn y que tan similar es
el adn con el de otros organismos te das
cuenta que este porcentaje viene de los
virus vienen de retrovirus antiguos los
cuales se incorporaron a la línea
germinal humana y después al adn humano
ya esto le llaman déjame bajar un poco
mi pantalla a esto lo llaman un
retrovirus endógenos este de aquí sería
un retrovirus endógenos
y lo que para mí es alucinante por no
decir que estas cosas no están muy
participativas es pensar que del 5% al
8% de nuestro adn viene de un virus y
esto es algo más que habla de la
variación genética ya esto lo podemos
llamar transferencia horizontal del adn
y como puedes imaginarte conforme un
virus va de una especie a otra conforme
va de una especie a una especie de
déjame ponerlo así si este virus va de
una especie a a una especie ve y puede
mutar de alguna forma que le permiten
filtrarse en las células de la especie
ve y tomará el adn que ya está es decir
el adn que lo hace a él ser él y todo
esto con él pero puede que cuando se
empiece a formar nuevos virus tomarán
adn de la célula hospedera y eso está
también increíble digamos que este es un
provino si bueno la parte de azul es la
parte del virus original y bueno esta
parte de color morado es la parte del
ade
del organismo ya veces cuando codifica
esto se toma unas pequeñas secciones del
adn de este organismo entonces a lo
mejor la mayoría del adn viral se va a
quedar justo aquí déjame dibujar esta
cápside algo más o menos así algo más o
menos así se va a ver así y bueno cuando
se transcribe se traduzca o al menos
cuando se traduzca o se replique este
virus va a pasar a ocupar esta cápside
pero tal vez se lleve con el parte del
adn de este organismo así que déjame
ponerlo así se va a llevar parte de este
adn de hecho está cortando partes del
adn de un organismo y lo lleva a otro
organismo lo toma de un miembro de una
especie a otro miembro de otra especie y
entonces puede moverse a través de las
especies y aquí está la idea de que
puede brincar entre las especies y para
mí esto hace apreciar que están
interconectadas están
especies podemos imaginar que somos
nosotros mismos y sólo nosotros podemos
reproducir entre nosotros y así tener
variación genética en la población pero
los virus introducen la noción de la
transferencia horizontal esto vía la
transducción así que aquí tengo
transferencia horizontal
sea horizontal
son
la cual es solo la idea de que cuando se
replica este virus pueda tomar un poco
del adn del organismo del cual de cierta
manera se aprovechan e infectar con ese
adn al siguiente organismo entonces lo
que realmente tienes es que este adn
está brincando de un organismo a otro
organismo y esto de cierta manera
unifica a todas las formas de vida a
base del adn y si todo esto no es lo
suficientemente escalofriante para ti
bueno tendrás que esperar porque de
hecho la parte más terrorífica está al
final pero bueno podemos seguir hablando
de todas las distintas clases de virus
porque esto nos sirve para estar
familiarizado con la parte de la
terminología cuando un virus ataca a una
bacteria como en este caso lo cual pasa
muy seguido y de hecho estudiamos
bastante a esta clase de virus porque
los virus que pueden atacar las
bacterias pueden ser una buena
alternativa a los antibióticos esto en
el caso en que la bacteria sea peor que
el virus en este caso tenemos a un virus
a su adn a esta bacteria y cuando ataca
la bacteria decimos que este virus se
llama bacteriófago así que déjenme
anotarlo este es un virus va te pidió
fago bacteriófago y recuerda que ya
hablamos de ellos como las bacterias
tienen las paredes duras entonces estos
se acercan e inquietan su adn dentro de
la bacteria bien cuando un virus isa a
la célula como aquí en este caso estamos
hablando de que tenemos un ciclo lítico
entonces déjame ponerlo league
ti
en este caso de aquí recuerda esto es
solamente terminología que es muy bueno
conocer si por ejemplo vas a tener un
examen de biología y cuando el virus se
incorpora al adn y permanece latente se
incorpora el adn de un hospedero y
permanece latente como por aquí como en
este caso a esto se le conoce como un
ciclo liso génico link
jericó
i
y un propio tiene un ciclo liso génico
en los eucariontes en organismos que
tienen membrana celular normalmente
cuando la gente habla del ciclo liso
génico está hablando de un adn viral que
permanece latente en el adn de una
bacteria sólo para darte una idea de
cómo se ve esto voy a traer por acá
abajo dos imágenes que tome de wikipedia
déjame bajar la pantalla para que las
veas claramente aquí las tengo la
primera es del cdc es decir de los
centros para control y prevención de
enfermedades de los estados unidos y
esta primera foto seguramente en un
inicio estaba en blanco y negro y ahora
que está a color puedes ver estos puntos
verdes y bueno toda esta célula que
tenemos aquí es un glóbulo blanco esta
gran cosa que tenemos aquí es un glóbulo
blanco así que déjenme anotarlo lo que
nos sirve para el sistema inmune
blanco así que aquí me falta un acento y
lo que ve saliendo aquí de color verde
esencialmente brotando de la superficie
de este glóbulo blanco y estos de aquí
en estos aquí éstos aquí son virus debe
y h 1b y h
y esto nos da un sentido de la escala
que realmente tienen estos ríos y ahora
que estás familiarizado con esta
terminología el vih es un virus que
infecta a los glóbulos blancos y el sida
es el síndrome que obtienes cuando tu
sistema inmune ya está debilitado y
muchas personas sufren de infecciones
que personas con un sistema inmune muy
fuerte muy resistente normalmente no
sufrirían y esto es aterrador a lo que
me refiero es que estas cosas entraron a
esta gran célula que tenemos aquí usaron
los mecanismos de la célula y con ello
van a reproducir su adn o su propio adn
y después estas cápsulas proteicas
brotan de la célula toman un poco de
esta membrana celular e incluso pueden
dejar algo de su adn detrás en el adn de
la célula y entonces cambian lo que era
esta célula en un inicio y bueno esta
otra imagen que tenemos aquí es de una
serie de bach
yo pago todos estos son bacteriófagos
así que voy a escribir bacteriófago los
recuerdas y esto es lo que te mencioné
antes esto de aquí es una bacteria y
bueno esta es su pared celular si te das
cuenta es una pared celular muy gruesa
no es fácil de penetrar la tenemos justo
por aquí tenemos esta pared celular
resistente y bueno lo difícil sería
entrar ahí mediante digamos la fusión de
membranas así que lo que pasa es que los
virus se colocan en el exterior de la
célula e inyectan su material genético
dentro de la bacteria justo así y como
puedes imaginarte esto nos da un poco de
sentido del tamaño que tienen los virus
a lo que me refiero es que todo esto es
un glóbulo blanco que se ve como un gran
planeta o algo así y esto es una
bacteria y estos pequeños son los virus
estos videos son aproximadamente un
centésimo de una bacteria y si te das
cuenta estos son
más pequeños que sentimos de una célula
por decirlo de alguna manera son
difíciles de filtrar y de mantener
afuera porque son partículas muy muy
pequeñas y si crees que estas son
solamente cosas exóticas que existen
para cosas como el vih b&h o el evo la
bola o el sars el sas tiene razón pero
también son cosas muy comunes como dije
al inicio de este vídeo
tengo gripa y tengo gripa porque algunos
virus infectaron mi tejido en mi cavidad
nasal y están causando que moke mucho y
estornuda y mucho más y bueno los virus
también pueden causar varicela o también
pueden causar el herpes simple y con
todo esto lo que quiero que sepas es que
están a nuestro alrededor casi te puedo
asegurar que te entran algunos virus
mientras hablas porque estos están a
nuestro alrededor y bueno si recuerdas
empecé este vídeo con una pregunta
enigmática que está justo aquí son los
virus vida cuando te los mostré por
primera vez justo aquí vimos que sólo
eran proteínas con una molécula de
ácidos nucleicos y no hacen nada y de
esta manera para mí no se ve como vida
no se mueven no tienen metabolismo no
comen no se reproducen pero de repente
si piensan en esto en lo que le hacen a
las células
y como las usan para reproducirse en
términos de negocios es minimizar los
activos no necesitan toda la maquinaria
porque pueden usar la maquinaria de
otras personas para replicarse a sí
mismos y esto lo puedes ver como la
forma de vida más inteligente porque no
se meten en todos los problemas que
tienen otras formas de vida lo cual
seguramente va a ser que te cuestiones
que es la vida e incluso que somos somos
estas cosas que contienen adn o somos
tan solo mecanismos de transporte para
el adn y estas cosas son digamos lo más
importante de manera que estas
infecciones virales son simplemente
batallas entre distintas formas de adn
de rn y demás en fin no quiero ponerme
muy filosófico pero espero que este
vídeo te haya dado una buena idea de qué
son los virus porque en mi opinión son
los pseudo organismos más fascinantes de
toda la biología